hey guys it's just aid and we were back
with another Mac Pro video I've been
using it for a few weeks now editing a
ton of projects and now I think it's
finally time to show you guys some of
the things that I've been working on
just a recap this is the 2.5 gigahertz a
28 core mac pro 4 terabyte solid state
drive 384 gigs of ram we also have dual
AMD Radeon Pro twos obviously this is a
machine that is built for professionals
I'm a professional but this is like
taking it to a whole nother level we're
talking people who are editing Star Wars
doing crazy motion capture doing things
that are far beyond making youtube
videos but I will say if I were to be
doing videos like I had for the unboxing
shooting 3 8k Reds editing a multicam
timeline then maybe this would be a
machine that I would need on a daily
basis so let me show you guys some of
the things that I've been doing to try
to push this thing to the limit the
first thing I want to show you is over
here and this is far beyond anything
that I would ever be doing with this
computer this is called photogrammetry
thank you to Alex Lindsey for sending me
this project and all of these photos he
took these a few years ago in India and
he sent me an email and such a scene do
you really want to push this Mac Pro to
the limit and of course I was like yeah
and if anybody's gonna do that it's
definitely gonna be Alex so we're taking
190 Bra images and turning it into a
lifelike 3d model and this app that
we're using is called meta shape now I
dragged all of these in this morning and
before I started the project I had no
idea how long this normally takes Alex
said it usually takes about 2 to 3 days
I was like what I thought this was gonna
take a few hours and I'd be done by the
time I started filming this video but so
far we're making really great progress
so you can see over here I have
everything being monitored we have all
of our cores available also monitoring
our CPU GPU in our memory and don't
forget I also have final cut open over
here with a 8k multicam edit happening
so there's a lot of stuff that I've been
doing all day while this has been
running so the first step in this whole
process was to align the photos no I
thought that I would use the bras
because it would take a lot longer he
also sent JPEGs but I was like no if
we're gonna do this we're gonna freakin
do it so it finds points of interest on
the photos sometimes they'll pick it up
to 100,000 points per image so it looks
for the same D
other images and when it finds him it
correlates those images with those
points and it builds a network between
all the images of these pairs and then
it uses those points to reverse-engineer
where the cameras needed to be to shoot
these images this will produce a point
cloud which will represent this entire
image in 3d this is a pretty intense
process next up we're building the mesh
so with this we're gonna be taking those
point clouds and that's gonna be
building actual surfaces so that that
can be rendered out in 3d or an AR app
then next we have building textures and
I know there was one other step that we
also wanted to try out but I left it out
of this one because it was incredibly
processor intensive so that would be
maybe a test that we do down the line
but I just wanted to get this process
started so far we're halfway done so I'm
gonna let this run and do its thing but
I'm gonna show you some of the things
that I've been working on here that I'm
more familiar with that I do on a daily
basis the first thing that I would show
you guys is a little HDR project that I
put together I've still been mostly
doing SDR because I've never really had
a moderate or that was able to show me
what true HDR looks like so now that I
have this I was really excited to test
this out so here's my HDR test clip here
so what I did to do this if you've never
worked with HDR before there's a ton of
really great tutorials that ripple
training has done which is what I
watched to get these settings so thank
you guys so I went in and I created a
wide gamut HDR I chose REC 2020 PQ you
also do make sure that the library that
you're working with is also set to HDR
you can check that by clicking on modify
in your library settings so you'll see
you have two options standard and wide
gamut HDR so it's not already set to HDR
you can change it here there's a few
different calibrations that you can set
your monitors to so right now I have
this one set to the 1600 nits and I'm
gonna set my second one sort of as my
reference monitor so we're gonna set
that to the HDR display setting here are
some of the custom display settings that
you have right now both of these
monitors is that two 1600 nits I'm gonna
scroll down here to the HDR video so
that's gonna be setting this monitor
over here to an HDR setting
we'll notice instantly that this screen
is much darker so if you do want to go
in and have a monitor that obviously
doesn't show HDR you can click show HG
Oreste home mapped what I'm gonna do is
since this monitor is now calibrate
we're gonna send this over there so you
guys can see the difference it looks
amazing
but it's really hard to show you guys if
you're not on an HDR monitor but here in
real life it's a huge difference it's
really wild we go into color and effects
this will show you the haze we can go
all the way up to 10 K luminance
normally you don't want to go past 100
so right now we're kind of pushing it at
400 we can boost this up even more
though let's bring you back down
[Music]
hey you guys forgot we still do have
that photogrammetry project that it's
still rendering in the background this
is kind of my first time working with
HDR so you guys do have any suggestions
or any tutorials that you've watched to
help you get a better HDR workflow
please leave those in the comments or
send me a tweet because this is
definitely something that I do want to
get more into YouTube does support HDR
but sometimes if you do export the video
in HDR I'm a little unsure of how it's
gonna process so for the most part I've
just been sticking with SDR but I do
want to try to experiment more with this
because obviously there are gonna be
more HDR televisions out there so I want
to get prepared that's on my to-do list
for 2020 but next up I want to show you
another fun little demo that I put
together this now is a test with some 8k
pro res 444 footage
I haven't yet out of the lot it's all
raw apples claiming that the Mac Pro can
do six streams of 8k pro res raw so I
thought let's try it out here we go and
don't forget we've got this entire
massive project running over here on the
side here's one stream two three four
and that's six now none of this is
grated yet so let's just maybe do that
while this is all running
cool oh that's weird one two three four
five six seven eight we've nine nine
streams running almost perfectly
simultaneously do you guys want to see
it again
I do let's make it bigger that James
Blunt I don't remember either but that's
what should be playing right now if I
wouldn't get a copyright strike but one
two five six streams beautifully here
they are a hole lined up it's the best
of my ability and I thought let's just
add three more and see what happens this
is a test that I was most excited to do
because I mostly shoot in 4k Apple says
you can get 23 streams of 4k and ProRes
raw and 16 streams of pro res 422 so
right now we have some pro res 422
footage running quite nicely and don't
forget we also have another project is
running in the background I'm just gonna
pop a lot on this while it's running see
what we can get oh wow it magically
worked just like that now if you think
this is exciting this is something that
took me way too long to do I by hand
don't put all of these in here's 25
running almost perfectly you may notice
there is a frame drop here and there but
when I did this initially I didn't have
anything else running in the background
so don't forget I'm gonna keep reminding
you we have a massive 3d render
happening at the same time as all of
this next I will show you another
project that I'm currently working on it
is an unboxing of a 1984 Mac I bought
this thing on eBay oh my gosh probably
two years ago at this point so since we
run into three 8k Reds to do the
unboxing of the Mac Pro which if you
haven't seen it I'll put a link in the
description but this was so fun so I
thought it'd be really great just shoots
and edit on the new Mac Pro so for this
project I didn't transfer to any of
these files I just took them basically
directly from the red to my hard drive
and put them right into this project
which I definitely don't recommend
because working with the transcoded pro
res footage is so much easier but I
really wanted to just test this out and
see what it can do so I put this all
into a multicam timeline all three 8k
Reds I just realized that I had this set
to better quality which is kind of crazy
because I usually edit in better
performance how do my breakfast I'm
trying to break the computer Tyler I
love editing interval to cam time limit
this was something that I learned this
year when I was working on my Final Cut
tutorial it has been so life-changing it
is so easy to edit multicam clips which
is usually what I'm filming with me
usually it have at least two cameras so
here's the project so hopefully I'll
have this finished soon now I'm gonna
turn onto my server so I can show you
guys some of the stuff that I had been
working on the unboxing that we shot
with this macro the footage of a such
high quality that I ran out of storage
space on every single thing that I had
in the only way that I was able to
finish this project was using a
jellyfish server which it's a little
loud I never thought it was loud until I
got the Mac Pro and realized how quiet
that thing is this thing is 75 terabytes
and I'm about halfway fool so let the
boot this up and I'll show you guys my
unboxing project
do you guys hear the difference it's
crazy
little update here we've aligned the
photos built the dense cloud and now
we're on the third step we're building
the mesh so I'm gonna keep letting this
run I'm gonna show you guys the unboxing
video that I worked on that you've
already seen posted here on YouTube this
was quite a process first of all I
didn't transcode any of the footage into
ProRes like I should have but I managed
to get it done and honestly I don't we
think some of my other computers would
have even been able to handle this at
all
this entire Mac Pro project I was
curious to see how big it was nineteen
point four seven terabytes at this rate
I'm gonna need several jellyfish servers
I mean this thing if I can store 75
terabytes
this is like three projects this macro
actually really isn't realistic either
but I am gonna embrace it
[Music]
I'll be doing some follow-up videos here
in the Mac Pro but for now this is
basically what I've been spending most
of my time doing shooting videos about
the macro and then editing them on the
Mac Pro so this was kind of a look at
what's been going on in the past couple
of weeks with it I'm really excited to
see the outcome of this project I'm not
sure if this 3d render is gonna be
completed by the time I'm done shooting
this video so if it's not I'm gonna do a
little follow-up and I will be posting
that outcome right after this I did have
to fly out for the holidays so I haven't
been back to my Mac Pro but I did want
to give you guys a look at this final 3d
render because it's pretty incredible
you can see as we click through here
here's the different steps that we did
we went through the tie points the depth
maps the bends cloud and then here is
the final 3d model is there not pretty
awesome and to think that this normally
would take two to three days whereas it
took my Mac Pro about 20 or so hours and
I feel like that's not the most accurate
number because I was editing a bunch of
8k projects in Final Cut while this was
rendering in the background there's
anything else you'd like to see me test
out on this Mac Pro please leave me a
comment send me a tweet let me know and
I will try to test it out on my next
video I have a bunch more videos planned
with this thing but for now I'm gonna go
enjoy the holidays and when we get back
there will be more Mac brokenness so see
you later
[Music]